with seven seconds to go  he missed it loose ball bridges has it  they gotta go it's payne  johnson for the win  cam time  two  three  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  cam johnson  with a stunner  at the buzzer  leaving the knicks shot  and in dismay  and the final signature moment coming  right here on his career night  and he did a great job of just teaming  it up he let the defense get are you let  the offensive defense get passed so  inadvertently he became the trailer  watch him slow down he's slowing down  he's waiting for that that was the play  and we saw it with villanova a few years  ago dribble all the way up throw it back  knocks down the three that was just  outstanding execution by the phoenix  suns knowing that they had no time out  so they had to go